this episode was made possible by
cheddar and their new YouTube channel
that makes videos covering business
technology media and news but without
the boring parts be sure to check out
their video on what part of space NASA
should explore next after this about a
year ago I made a video speculating what
NASA could do with the US military
budget it's pretty amazing how much
things have changed in that time from a
massive increase to military funding
under President Trump to the amazing
achievements of SpaceX projects under
the direction of Elon Musk with that new
information in mind it's time to revisit
our most popular video with a more
specific goal how quickly could we
establish a fully functional
self-sufficient Mars colony with the
current US military budget before we
begin it's important to note that the
numbers in this video while largely
based on the best estimates we currently
have are still wildly speculative so
take all of this with a grain of salt we
all know the US military is enormous
many would say unnecessarily absurdly
enormous others believe it's important
to ensure no one would dare challenge
the United States including those pesky
allies whichever camp you fall into the
fact of the matter is that US military
spending is greater than the next 10
countries combined the official budget
for 2018 which originally would have
been capped at 549 billion per the
budget and Control Act ended up a
whopping seven hundred billion dollars
not including the money spent defending
the nation on the homefront that's a lot
of money 58 percent of the total
discretionary budget America spends more
than half of its non mandatory funding
to ensure its military is the biggest it
can possibly be
so what does this massive increase in
funding get us 10 more combat ships
increased production of the f-35 and
f-18 aircraft a quote modernizing of the
nuclear triad to enhance deterrence
20300 more troops and the creation of a
so called space Corps a new branch of
the Air Force meanwhile NASA gets just
shy of 20 billion dollars to fund not
only its own ambitious projects but also
to help fund smaller enterprises pocket
change compared to the military but
historically speaking the space industry
has been able to do amazing things with
relatively little money and more
recently with the successes of SpaceX
and its reusable rockets space travel is
becoming more and more financially
viable in the past Rockets have been too
damaged to reuse for
your flights and it can cost hundreds of
millions of dollars to build new ones by
figuring out how to safely reuse their
rockets SpaceX has drastically reduced
the upfront cost of sending cargo or
humans into space back in 2016 when musk
first unveiled his plans for
establishing a human colony on Mars he
estimated that it would cost ten billion
dollars to get twelve astronauts to the
Red Planet
however he figured that if SpaceX could
get 1 million people to go it would
reduce the ticket price to just $200,000
each that's still a massively expensive
undertaking but keep in mind that prices
for 1 million people ok let's take a
step back here before we look at cost
what would it take to establish a
self-sufficient colony on Mars obviously
first you'd need a way to get humans
there safely and efficiently SpaceX has
their interplanetary transit system
concept and their bf are a massive 30
foot wide hundred fifty seven foot tall
vessel with room for a hundred people in
40 cabins as well as eight stories of
cargo space that's not a bad start but
even paired with reusable rockets at a
rate of a hundred passengers per launch
it would be hugely expensive to either
have a fleet of these bf ours or shuttle
just a handful of them back and forth on
the six-month round-trip between Earth
and Mars musk has mentioned his idea to
build a so called Mars colonial fleet
consisting of 1,000 ships to ferry new
colonists to the Red Planet besides
transportation you need to have the
infrastructure on Mars to house and
support the arriving colonists and to
refuel and launch the ships back towards
Earth assuming the Martian
infrastructure had to be completed
before the first colonists could arrive
SpaceX
likely in cooperation with NASA and
other international space programs would
have to build housing transportation
food water and other resource production
facilities hospitals schools solar
arrays storage units communication posts
and innumerable other necessities for a
large number of people such an
undertaking is incredibly expensive even
on earth there have been a number of
science and tech centric cities built
over the past several decades but the
most current example and therefore the
easiest to compare cost wise is Masdar
City in the United Arab Emirates
Masdar is planned to house many fewer
people than the proposed Martian colony
roughly 50,000 people vs. 1 million but
its goal is largely similar an emphasis
on clean renewable technology packed
into a highly planned specialized in
research and technology intensive hub
the estimated cost of developing
the entire city is around 22 billion
dollars and it's expected to be
completed by 2030 a full 24 years after
work began building a similar city on
Mars to support 20 times the population
of Masdar will be exponentially more
challenging and expensive so with those
requirements in mind let's crunch some
numbers
assuming SpaceX does decide to build the
Mars colonial fleet of 1,000 ships what
would it cost it's estimated that one
bfr will cost around a hundred eighty
five million dollars times 1000 for the
full fleet that's a hundred eighty five
billion dollars or about twenty six and
a half percent of the annual US military
budget estimates for actual flights of
each bfr vary widely but assuming a per
flight cost of 50 million dollars and
assuming each vessel carried exactly 100
colonists every time you get a cost of
500 billion dollars or seventy one and a
half percent of the annual US military
budget so to construct a Mars colonial
fleet and fly 1 million people to
another planet on paper you're looking
at 97% of what the u.s. spends on the
military every year of course this
doesn't take into account maintenance
and repairs for each vessel or
additional make up flights or any number
of unforeseen costs which could quickly
add up okay what about the Martian
infrastructure assuming a one to one
cost to scale Masdar city up to a
million people and rebuild it on Mars
you're looking at roughly 440 billion
dollars of course the cost of building
on a different planet will be much much
higher than building on earth since you
need to get the materials there or mine
and fabricate them on site then actually
build an entire city in a difficult
environment at this point we really
don't know just how expensive space
construction will be a lot will depend
on how much usable material we can
extract from the Martian terrain as
shipping it from Earth will be
incredibly expensive let's assume
constructing the Martian colony would be
ten times more expensive than
constructing it here on earth that gives
us a ballpark four point four trillion
dollar figure or roughly six years worth
of the US military budget so in an ideal
situation on paper it looks like we
could build a self-sustaining Martian
colony for the cost of about seven years
of the US military budget seven years to
get a million people living on another
planet
of course that brings us to one point we
haven't considered time planning
developing building traveling to and
from Mars all of these things take time
even with all the money in the world we
couldn't hope to get a Martian colony up
and running in less than a few decades
Elon Musk puts his estimate anywhere
between forty and a hundred years until
his colony is fully operational so while
it may seem a little ridiculous that
what could be humanity's greatest
achievement could be fully funded with
just seven years of military spending or
heck you could just split the budget in
half and still have the largest military
in the world by far and fund the project
in 14 years while it may seem ridiculous
even if we did have the money to start
today it would take us a very long time
until we could look up at the night sky
and know there are a million human
beings living on that distant speck of
light that being said if we did start
soon there would likely be people alive
today who would live to see humanity
become a multiplanetary species I think
that's worth half the fighter jets per
year
space exploration is one of our
favourite topics here on second thought
so we were more than happy to partner
with cheddar on this video
cheddar recently launched their YouTube
channel and are making videos that cover
business technology media and news but
without the boring parts we just watched
their video on what part of space NASA
should explore next
and definitely recommend you check it
out too and if you like it consider
subscribing to their channel which
covers all sorts of interesting and fun
topics and watch more of their videos
after finally caving in to the many
requests over the past year I actually
really enjoyed revisiting this topic if
there's another topic you'd like to see
covered in an upcoming video mention it
in the comments below and I'll do my
best to get to it if you enjoyed this
video consider subscribing and clicking
the bell to support the channel and
check out these playlists full of other
great content as always thanks for
watching and we'll see you next week